it is hard to think of a pmqs like it is
a time when a prime minister's had to
row back on so much so quickly so we
thought we'd do something a little bit
different we're taking a forensic look
through prime minister's questions in
our edit let's start by looking at the
moment that Liz truss walked into the
chamber here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
so you can see the Tory bench is pretty
no well pretty busy I mean there aren't
many gaps on the Troy benches in the
same way we saw towards the end of Boris
Johnson's Premiership but it was muted
it was perhaps not the enthusiastic
response she would have wanted she of
course knows that this is a huge moment
from her for her Premiership sitting
next to her was Jeremy Hunt I think we
can see them here now there you go
they're they're chatting away they are
the two people at the heart of
government he is a man who was
dismantled her entire economic Vision in
the last week she looks pretty relaxed
but she knows the next 45 minutes are
going to be absolutely crucial and we've
been looking to at the mood on the
opposition benches unsurprisingly
um Kier stammer looking pretty buoyant
they are riding high in the polls if we
go on to the next clip here here we go
let's play this so why is she still here
everybody
there we go I mean you can see we've
circled there mark Spence this is
someone who was team Rishi right till
the end these are the sorts of people
that Liz truss really needs to be
winning over and you can see I mean
their glum faces there and on the front
bench too I mean Anne-Marie trevelyan is
on her phone you can see I mean this is
not the enthusiasm on the front benches
that the Prime Minister wants she knows
that she is clinging on to power she
needs all the support she can get and if
we keep playing I think we can see a
wide shot there you go I mean look at
the contrast between the labor benches
the MPS gesticulating and the Tory glum
benches on the other side Michael Gove
we've circled there standing on the
sidelines he of course has been seen as
a big trouble maker someone who's making
his views very clearly known at the Tory
Party Conference so Liz truss is trying
to win over her back benches we know
that there was some red meat for the
party faithful during prime minister's
questions to get today she was clearly
trying to attack labor on the unions on
strikes if you have a listen to the next
clip we can see that
taking steps to crack down on the
militant unions now what what Mr Speaker
now sometimes premises questions can
descend into playground politics we
really see the theatrics here there's a
short distance between the Tory benches
and the labor benches they see James
cleverly gesticulating doing the money
gesture towards a labor bench is clearly
a dig at the money that labor get from
the union something that they of course
deny so that is the theatrics of prime
minister's questions but of course there
were important policy moments too and
this was one of them if we play we keep
playing the next clip yeah here we go
we have been clear in our Manifesto that
we will maintain the triple lock and I
am completely committed to it so is the
chancellor
okay so this has been the big question
in the last 24 hours is the chancellor
committed to the triple lock on pensions
this is something that neither Downing
Street or number 11 would confirm in the
last 24 hours that all eyes really have
been on the new chancelet Jeremy Hunt we
know it is something that some tour MPS
have publicly made clear they obviously
want to see protected from their
perspective let's have a look at what
the chancellor said in response to that
or did in response to that
and we've even slow motioned it for you
I think there we go
that's a nod from the chancellor so uh
the chancellor there suggesting
um that the pensions triple lock will be
protected which is a significant policy
moment but as I say you know this was an
extraordinary prime minister's questions
a PM who is Clinging On by her by her
fingertips to power this was an
important moment for her to show that
she had Authority has she done enough I
think we will see in the next few hours
if MPS are satisfied with her
performance